Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute ein schnelles No Bake Rezept.
Ich habe mir gedacht jetzt, wo es so warm ist und ihr mir unter meinem...
was war das, das letzte oder das vorletzte? Unter dem Blätterteig Video habt ihr mir geschrieben
ihr möchtet auch für den Sommer gerne No Bake Rezepte haben.
Schnelle Rezepte, die praktisch sind und die ihr gut vorbereiten könnt.
So und jetzt machen wir ein Windbeutel No Bake Rezept mit Erdbeeren.
Erdbeeren: ihr wisst ich liebe es! Muss man komplett auskosten.
Ich hab aber heute allerdings muss ich ehrlich sagen tiefgekühlte Erdbeeren da und frische nehme ich
später für die Deko weil ich nicht mehr so viele frische da habe.
So und jetzt starten wir direkt. Ich habe hier Joghurt. Nehmt gerne zehnprozentigen
oder 3,5-prozentigen, ich hab jetzt hier den 3,5-prozentigen noch da gehabt
aber den komplett fettarmen, also 1,5 und 0,1 würde ich jetzt hier nicht empfehlen.
So, den gebe ich jetzt mit dazu. Dann haben wir noch Mascarpone, ich habe heute auf Sahne verzichtet
dann nehme ich noch Mascarpone dazu. Die könntet ihr jetzt auch durch Frischkäse ersetzen.
Und da kommt dann Puderzucker mit rein und der Zitronen- also der Schalenabrieb einer Zitrone.
Hamza du bist so still, sag mal was!
(H: Meine zweite Kamera ist ausgegangen, einfach so!)
Nein! Nein!
(H: *lacht* Ist nicht schlimm!)
Okay! Ihr wisst ich hab Joghurt rein gegeben und Mascarpone.
Hamza holt jetzt den Akku und dann machen wir weiter.
Ja? Geht sie wieder?
(H: M-hm!)
Okay. Ganz sicher?
(H: Ja!)
So, weiter geht's! Genau,  Puderzucker für die Süße habe ich euch ja gerade schon gesagt.
Und ich nehme auch keine Küchenmaschine, wir rühren jetzt alles mit dem Schneebesen.
Jetzt habe ich hier eine Bio-Zitrone. Wichtig ist eben, dass sie nicht gespritzt ist und Bio ist
damit wir auch die Schale verwenden können weil die schmeckt soo aromatisch!
Dafür nehme ich jetzt meine Zitrusreibe, also meine feine Reibe, die geht auch für Käse.
Verlinke ich euch in die Infobox.
Und ich werde auch gleich noch ein bisschen Zitronensaft reingeben, aber nur so ungefähr 1 Teelöffel.
Um den Geschmack zu verfeinern gebe ich jetzt noch Vanilleextrakt dazu und ich bin der Meinung:
Zitrone und Vanille ist einfach das perfekte Team. Genauso wie du und ich Hamza!
(H: Oh, das ist aber süß gesagt!<3)
Das ist aber lieb, ne? So, gehst du jetzt den Müll rausbringen und machst mir danach 'nen Kaffee?
So, schon fertig! Also die Creme ist eine sehr weiche, ich mache jetzt auch extra keine Sahnefest oder
irgendeine Gelatine oder Agartine rein. Und ich probier jetzt mal ob es mir genug Süße ist,
sonst kann ich das ja immer noch verändern.
Mmmmh!
(H: Da hätte auch ein halber Teelöffel gereicht!)
Perfekt! Nächstes Mal nehme ich einen Esslöffel, extra wegen dir!
So und jetzt nehme ich mir die Erdbeeren - die habe ich auftauen lassen, ihr könnt auch frische nehmen -
und die püriere ich jetzt ganz einfach.
Ich habe noch Wasser und Zucker mit zur Erdmasse gegeben, einfach für die Konsistenz und für die Süße.
Und jetzt können wir das Ganze schichten.
Ich habe dazu noch Windbeutel aus dem Tiefkühlfach genommen,
das sind diese Erdbeer-Windbeutel. Ihr könnt sie natürlich auch selber machen
aber ganz ehrlich: Wer hat da Lust drauf bei dem Wetter? Ich zugegebenermaßen nicht!
Aber ich verlinke euch auch mein Windbeutel Video hier unten in die Infobox.
Und ich guck mal wie ich das schichte. Ich glaube ich nehme jetzt als Erstes dieses Erdbeerpüree.
Ich will ja auch, dass das schick aussieht.
So und dann gebe ich da - ein oder zwei? Weiß ich gar nicht, einfach mal schauen.
(H: Ich glaub einer reicht erstmal!)
Erstmal reicht einer. Es kommt auch oft die Größe an, ne?
So und dann von der leckeren Creme.
Und dann würde ich nochmal mit dem Erdbeerpüree abschließen
und dann gebe ich frische Erdbeeren und noch frische Minze mit drauf.
(H: So ein Klecks würde glaube ich reichen!)
In die Mitte?
(H: Ja, so ein Klecks!)
Okay.
(H: Ja, reicht, reicht! Perfekt.)
So!
So, ich mache jetzt doch Strudel hier oben, einfach mit einem Zahnstocher rein.
(H: Ja, sieht besser aus!)
Ja, finde ich auch.
So, dann haben wir's auch schon! Wie schnell ging das bitte?
Also wenn ihr jetzt sagt: "Nee, dat dauert mir zu lange!", dann weiß ich auch nicht weiter!
Das ging jetzt echt mega mega schnell.
(H: Das ist perfekt für den Garten, auch für Terrassen wenn man Besuch hat. Balkon..)
Ja. Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall! Für den Besuch, einfach um sich selbst zu verwöhnen,
einfach wenn ihr auf dem Balkon chillen möchtet.. also das passt perfekt und es ist sehr erfrischend!
Und euch wünsche ich jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen!
Ihr könnt die ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in der Videobeschreibung lesen.
Da könnt ihr neben dem Titel den Pfeil anklicken und dann kommt ihr da direkt drauf.
Ich sage das jetzt gerne mal extra dazu weil es sind ganz viele neue hier in der Kikimunity,
die wissen das vielleicht noch nicht. Und wenn ihr weitere Rezeptvorschläge habt, immer immer her damit!
Und dann würde ich mal sagen: bis zu meinem nächsten Video! Tschüss, eure Kiki!